[Music]
this morning on the dish a restaurant in
Boulder Colorado where the food could
not be fresher because it comes straight
off the chef's own Farm almost
everything they cook at Bramble and hair
is grown and raised at owners Jill and
Eric skoken's farm from the heirloom
tomatoes and lettuce to the pigs sheep
and geese it means a menu that changes
with the season and it's delighting
their fans
just outside of Boulder in the foothills
of the Colorado Rockies suburban sprawl
has forged a friendship with fruitful
Farmland oh there's a bunch of good ones
right there oh yeah look at that
perfectly right it's where folks like
Eric skokan and his wife Jill have
learned to grow their living I'm looking
for ones that have a huge amount of
flavor farming these fields for produce
or hurting their flock of sheep the
Sheep they see new grass
but it's important for us to like move
the Sheep continually so they don't kill
off the grass here
[Laughter]
look at them go
let's go cans 450 acres dub black cat
Farm is just half the story in town he
runs the popular Bramble in hair where
his seasonal menu is almost entirely
sourced from his own produce and
livestock
did we mention he pulls double duty as
the chef too the Farms that Supply the
restaurants to demand yeah yeah and they
feed each other absolutely there's Farm
to Table and then there's Farm to Table
ish right and we're not Farm to tableish
We Are Farmers tables right I think
really the important thing is for us
that it's been authentic authenticity
only a only a handful of restaurants in
the U.S or like Bramble and hair one
part Farm one part kitchen growing
nearly their entire menu themselves in
the restaurant we need the hearty bulky
things the potatoes and the carrots and
the beets and then we also need the
things that are really delicate and then
these things sort of get sprinkled on
they give this sense of life and
freshness to the substance that we've
grown in the other field Eric and Jill
were first inspired almost 20 years ago
while on an unforgettable trip in Basque
country in the south of France we ate in
a little restaurant Auberge koshoki one
of my best meals I've ever had in my
life everything they ate was locally
produced and optimally fresh that they
decided is what they wanted to recreate
at home it was just magic you know when
when you just know yeah that it makes
sense they opened a restaurant and began
a small backyard garden in which they
quickly outgrew moving on to open land
outside of town that was the idea of
expanding the farm and doing the big
things out there and we loved it right I
got to drive a tractor and really maybe
that's what it was okay
right within a decade a few Acres became
hundreds and with it a full-blown Farm
we've got about 500 cheap we do about 24
geese a year we do about 120 Hogs a year
lots of chickens we have you know four
dogs it's a menagerie it's we have
animals all over the place today's
Harvest is on Full display we're
swimming in produce coming out of the
bed right it's like the fall is harvest
season it is and today over the last
week this is like the peak of the peak
of the peak everything skoken serves up
screams seasonal one of my favorite
dishes in the fall let's take the whole
season condensed it down into a stew
Ratatouille style a medley of sauteed
peppers eggplant and tomatoes spooned
into an edible soul and then we fill
that inside of Little Summer squashes
and then one of my favorite cheeses ever
telegio that we put on top and it's like
it's like heaven candlelit dinners may
be the fanciest way to get a taste of
what the farm has to offer but it
certainly isn't all of it we have our
Farm Stand we have our farm delivery
truck we do dinners out here at the farm
we have farm tours buses of kindergarten
kids running around through the
Strawberry Patch we have opened
ourselves up to the community here for
16 years it's really about feeding
communities and during the pandemic
while National supply shortages left
supermarkets empty-handed black cat Farm
was able to supply the demand we didn't
have that problem in fact we were here
on this Farm we were you know inundated
with food we were able to retool our
operation
like that and literally within days we
were able to you know close the
restaurant open up a Farm Stand and
start taking care of you know customers
in in the community and that community
of customers in turn took care of them
at the beginning of covid we lost our
son Kelsey two years ago on the road by
their home their son was killed when a
dump truck smashed into his car through
all this process we have you know
reevaluated what we want to do in life
many things have that we thought were
important really you know for Jill and
me are not you know particularly
important anymore with this
life-altering tragedy their passions and
Inspirations are clearer than ever
before moving forward we are really
excited to cook at the farm have dinners
at the farm It's the final piece of the
dream they started cooking up two
decades decades ago giving diners the
full Farm experience eating just feet
from the fields in these cozy
greenhouses equipped with wood stoves
creating it such that I can walk right
over there Harvest a few things walk
into the kitchen and have the food come
out a couple minutes later creating that
experience for people it's enriching for
me to be able to do it it's enriching
for our customers and for the community
as well it's it's the best win-win out
there
and that when women will be coming back
at the beginning of next year obviously
covet restrictions now off they had to
sort of revamp in that way
and we will be right back
[Music]
welcome back oh thank you thank you I
have to tell you this is called the
Fashion on Pearl and it is I
know it's Rye it's basil syrup it's
lemon juice it's ginger beer and it is
so special so as the kids say that slaps
yes is that what they said I think so
I'll have to check but for right after
Thanksgiving everything looks so
delicious it really was bad they Eric
and Jill were delightful and I have to
full disclosure I knew nothing about
what they'd endured during covet nothing
um there was there was nothing in the
research and
he just spelled it on me like that and
lost their son and they lost their son
and they are just building back their
lives and Bramble and hair and black cat
Farm has helped them right so much in
the community has helped so much in
restoring their faith and their purpose
and so it was just a wonderful thing to
be there and hear that they are on the
mend I mean so I'm sure people can
understand you can't even imagine
getting out of bed every day when you
endure a loss like that so to see what
they've done that's what Eric said right
he and Jill reevaluated what was
important it really seems that Spirit
really comes through and and what they
make and what they do great story great
story thank you